jennifer lopez is cleaning up her
instagram i'm excited about it the star
deleted all picks of ex alex rodriguez
from her instagram feed four months
after announcing their split i'm
thrilled traces of the baseball player
do still appear on her igtv videos
including this one where she celebrates
her mom lupe's 75th birthday
there's also this one from when j-lo and
a-rod spent time zooming with president
joe biden and his wife jill
what we're hanging on to right now there
you go there you go jlo has also since
unfollowed her ex though we should note
he still follows her and has pics of her
up on his instagram page like whoa
shortly after jlo split from a-rod she
rekindled things with ex ben affleck it
feels really good and it's really nice
and things are getting very serious last
week the pair was spotted touring a new
home together at an estate in talluca
lake california and who could forget the
romantic european escape last month
there's a lot going on in france right
now did you call ben up and say what
gives man why didn't you give me an
invite
no i think that's a private trip i don't
think i'd be invited on that one i might
be a bit of a third wheel of course ben
and jen have a whole lot of history they
dated back in 2002 and got engaged later
that year i think we had chemistry as
actors from the first moment we started
working they met while filming their
movie geely i'm sorry do we know each
other not yet you guys want to get used
to seeing us again
the pair ended up calling it quits
shortly before their wedding in 2004. it
was my first kind of heartbreak really
yeah i mean i had like a puppy love
heartbreak when i was like 12. you know
what i mean but i don't really count
that one it was my first like adult
heartbreak it was just one of those
things you know i was an adult we were
about to get married it didn't work out
and it was just a bad heartbreak like
you know just one of those breakups that
really you know it was like
a tough one for me fast forward to now a
source recently told et quote they have
insane on another level chemistry they
are both super passionate and our head
over heels with each other just like
they once were and we've learned that
the pair feels like this is it give it
away but it has a very good
[Music]